[Music]
abolishing the gender ministry
prosecuting women who made false
accusations of sex crimes
blaming south korea's low birth rate on
feminism
these are some of the pledges south
korea's new president yoon sagar has
made to gain male voters
[Music]
fighting against him is 26 year old pak
tihan
[Music]
park made a name for herself as an
activist who helped uncover a harrowing
digital sex crime network on telegram
offering images and videos of women in
humiliating and degrading poses or
videos of women harming themselves
we found chat rooms called the nth room
in july 2019 we spent five to six hours
every day collecting evidence scrolling
through these chat rooms
she was in journalism school and with a
classmate began an investigative project
into the online exploitation of women
they ended up bringing down the nth room
their investigation became the subject
of a netflix documentary called cyber
hell
pac revealed her identity in january and
became a senior advisor to the liberal
party's candidate for president
[Music]
i was afraid of the consequences of
revealing my identity i feared would my
family be okay but after two years of
activism i realized that my voice was
dwindling
since then she's emerged as a fiery
opponent president yun who swept into
office on a wave of anti-feminist
rhetoric and his gender split strategy
there's a huge gap between women and men
on how they perceive feminism and it's a
shame politicians used it in the
election
she's now the co-chair of the democratic
party
it's remarkable that a woman in her 20s
is the leader of the main opposition
party in korea but when i see a movement
to limit and reduce me to only gender
issues i want to tell them this is not a
gender issue it's a social issue
i think in south korea there's this
really unhappy collision of a society
which is incredibly technologically
advanced with super fast internet speeds
super high rates of smartphone ownership
with a country which is really lagging
behind on gender equality and so i think
that when you have that combination of
factors it's kind of combustible as far
as women's safety online and the ways in
which technology are used to further
abuse women
the risks exist in both virtual and real
life fueled by an unusual proliferation
of illegal videos taken by micro cameras
which come in various hidden forms
ranging from glasses to car keys
over 10 000 cases of digital sex crime
were reported in 2021 and 21.5 percent
of them had to do with illegal filming
it's too easy to commit a digital sex
crime there are people online who have
accumulated wealth by buying selling and
sharing these illegally filmed photos
and videos for decades there were also
cases where they said that they would
erase these things that they were
digital morticians and take money from
the victims to erase them this all
together has become a cartel
of those convicted of digital sex crimes
between 2016 and 2020 more than 81
percent have only received suspended
sentence or a fine
and just 9.4 percent were sentenced to
jail time of those imprisoned 82 percent
received less than 10 months
the legal system shouldn't just be about
prosecuting people it should also be
offering options to people like going to
court to get an order to say that
someone who has an image is ordered not
to share it or is ordered to destroy it
it should also be possible to go to
court and ask for damages
[Music]
there is an urgent need for a discussion
between the government and the police on
how to deal with sexual exploitation and
the sharing of these materials
experts say one of the reasons behind
what is animating the party of men
involved in any sort of digital sex
crime comes from pervasive misogyny in
korean culture
i think one of the ways that you see
that play out is that it seems quite
socially acceptable to a lot of people
in south korea to a lot of men and boys
to consume these images to create these
images is kind of seen by some men as a
kind of fun sort of male bonding rather
than being seen as gender-based violence
which is what it is
park faces an uphill battle men hold
more than a whopping 81 percent of
parliamentary seats in south korea
i saw a lot of sexual comments about me
that i wouldn't have gotten if i were a
man if i don't deal with them now it
would happen to another female
politician in her twenties i hope we can
grow into a society that guarantees more
diversity regardless of generation and
gender
[Music]